on the mound the opener tonight the
right-hander john curtis and kyle the
marlins can add another name to the list
of starting pitchers here in 2021
and four pitches to vr he draws a lead
off walk to start this game right away
from john curtis
right away vr's running pitch was a
breaking ball and vr steals easily
that's his fourth of the season for the
minutes now he's in scoring position
right away
it's this ball hard toward the right
field corner and it's going to drive in
a run jonathan vr will come home
francisco lindor gets the mitch rolling
right away an rbi double and it's one
nothing
[Applause]
smith reached for it
carried a bit but magnari sierra is
there to make the catchling doors
tagging this time sierra does have a
strong arm a close play with the ball
gets away and it rolls toward the
marlins dugout it's going to bring home
a run lindor will score and it helps the
mets take a two-nothing lead well
strowman's only had a handful of starts
but these toyota numbers will show you
he's had two different seasons already
3-0 era under one in his first few
starts in his last five 0-4 era a touch
over four chisholm running again ball in
the dirt good throw
and it's in time jazz chisholm thrown
out for the first time this season now
it's two and two on dickerson with
nobody on
peraza with a diving stop
good throw to get dickerson good enough
at least as drury holds the bag and
avoids a collision to win the innings
adam duvall will lead things off
pitch to duvall is a ground ball sharply
hit by the diving shortstop base hit
left center so for the second straight
inning the marlins get gonna lead off
single
and it helps when he goes the other way
andy to right over maven's head and one
hops over the wall
and duvall
will have to stop at third
leone with a fly ball out to center
fargus moves out toward left center
field here comes duval here comes the
throw it's cut off
and sandy leone has himself a zac fly
it's two to one
swinging a missed strike three strowman
gets sierra to win the inning
a couple of strikeouts for marcus
strowman but he did give up a run and
now it's a two-to-one mets league
pop the fourth to go for the marlins
pretty good slider exactly
it's the strikeout of maven
i was reading uh somewhere where zach
popp at one time was considered the best
high school pitcher
in canada
out of brampton ontario
ball four to dominic smith he draws the
walk the first base runner for the mets
since lindor's double back in the first
inning
tomas nino with a charge into this one
deep toward left center that ball is off
the wall dominic smith on his way to
third being waved home relay throw heads
toward the plate not in time
rbi double tomas nito he's six for his
last 11. and the mets have a 3-1 lead
powerful swing that hits the ball over
the left fielder's head and one hop the
wall
and by the time dickerson could get to
it and get it in
dominic smith showed great speed and
scoring the mets third run
there's a base hit into center field
here comes the throw from sierra gets to
the plate
[Applause]
you gotta be kidding me
what a throw by sierra and what a play
on the back end by san diego
well it's another outfield assist for
the marlins
few teams have been better this year
sierra with a strike plato the pick and
the tag
three to one
sandy leone drove in the marlins run
with a sacrifice fly in the second
inning
cooper is running leone takes strike
three throw by neato it's a strike about
throw him out inning ending double play
tomas nito from his knees gets garrett
cooper and the mets keep a two-run lead
well we go to the last of the sixth
inning full count here on rojas
swing and a miss strike three
five straight strikeouts for marcus
strowman again another change-up from
strowman in account that rojas thought
he's gonna get a fastball what's the
reaction from strowman
a little pound on the chest and a little
hop
dickerson makes contact lindor trying to
make the play and he does scoop by drury
at first as francisco lindor retires
dickerson
that pumped up strowman as much as it
did lindor
he is playing shifted away from his
natural position up the middle had to go
far to his right and got enough on that
throw to get dickerson dickerson doesn't
have a ton of speed but he's not slow by
any means as the mets have a 3-1 lead
against the marlins brian anderson will
lead off against marcus stroman who's
retired seven straight
payoff pitch
is low the marlins draw their first walk
tonight
strowman's going to come out of this
game with nobody out in the seventh and
hand it off to miguel castro garrett
cooper will step in castro deals
and cooper sits one in the air left
field this one's indeed this one's gone
we're tied in the seventh
garrett cooper does it again
what a nice swing that swing is really
starting to come around for garrett
cooper last couple of weeks
around on the road trip big night last
night to end the trip and i think that's
clearly the biggest swing of the year
for garrett cooper
leone strikes out on the slider that's
the first out of the inning
sierra swings and misses another slider
another strikeout
sierra's fan three times tonight
that's in there strike three calls so
castro strikes out three in a row but
before that a game-tying two-run homer
from garrett cooper it's 3-3
new pitcher for the mitch is trevor
maine it's been a little more of a
struggle for trevor of late has given up
runs in three of his last four outings
swinging a miss strike three
fastball up we see may get a lot of
strikeouts up
above the zone
and jazz chisholm chased got just a
piece here it comes
and inside ball four just in off the
inside corner there they go and here it
comes inside ball four they're loaded
cooper with the bases loaded has been a
monster trevor may trying to quiet it
right here
tie game in the eighth base is loaded
the full count pitch
swaying and amid strike three
trevor may punches out garrett cooper he
strands the bases loaded in the eighth
as the marlins come up empty three three
scores so now it's jerice familia three
and two
is in the dirt and the marlins
have the potential winning run on base
to start the night
and a base heading to right field for
magneris sierra
leone will stop at second
gets under this one lindor into the
outfield makes the catch
and a huge first out for familia
that was in the strike zone it's deep to
left dominic smith is there to make the
catch
three
familia goes to the slider he wipes out
rojas
it's a scoreless ninth will tovar will
be the batter against flora
high chopper that'll move a runner and
might be a hit barehand from rojos has
no play will tovar
the old bouncer off the plate
it's an infield hit and the mets have
runners on the corners
[Applause]
ground ball
backhanded by cooper flips to florida
what a play
what a play by cooper and floro
edwin diaz into the ball game is 18th
this year
swinging to miss and actually gets away
from neato and up to third goes rojas
and duvall strikes out 100 at the
litters
swing and a miss strike three
it was a high fastball and a fantastic
job by edwin diaz to hang a zero in the
10th let's get into the 11th inning here
lendore the ground ball base hit and for
the second straight inning the mets have
first and third with nobody out
to third and they got him
that's a good coordinated play between
brian anderson and simber they got to
coordinate that
he's got to get to the bag simber has to
make the throw and they got
first and third one out khalil lee is
now coming up it's this ball hard down
the line toward the corner it is a fair
ball dominic smith scores and khalil lee
with his first big league hit his first
big league contact and his first big
league rbi it's four to three in the 12.
hit hard by fargus to right diving
attempt to get by duvall two runs will
score janeshway fargus running around
the bases he might call all the way
around he's being waved home relay throw
to the plate fargus is
out at home but it's a two-run triple
and a 6-3 lead for the bets
6-5 the score so now jacob barnes
will try to get the save here
high papa it's playable for cameron
mabin and the mets win in 12 innings
tonight a 6-5 battle in miami